what is up everybody it is axelbeatz
here for anime uproar and today i will
be going over every single new stand in
jojo's bizarre adventure part 6 stone
ocean for those who might have missed it
the series began streaming on netflix
recently and there's already 12 episodes
up covering the first third or about 50
chapters of the manga we will be
discussing all the stands which make
appearances in that time as well as the
remaining ones in the series if you
enjoy seeing stone ocean content on this
channel and you want to see more you
know what to do hit that like button and
if you're new here to anime uproar be
sure to hit the subscribe button as well
and select all notifications i know
these seem like pretty small things but
they mean a lot for the channel and they
help ensure that you get notified when
new content goes live
you can also follow anime upward at
anime upper on twitter and instagram or
you can follow myself at excellionyt
obviously there will be manga spoilers
in this video as we are covering the
entirety of the stone ocean manga but if
you're okay with that let's jump into
the video so the first stand that we
meet belongs to our protagonist jolene
cujo and it's called stone free however
as it is tradition in the jojo series
the localized name was changed to become
stone ocean originally stone free is a
reference to the jimi hendrix song of
the same name
stonefree is one of the most versatile
stands in part 6 by far jillian can
unravel her body into string and
manipulate it freely stone freely if you
will the string isn't extremely durable
but it can be sharp enough to cut
someone and it's precise enough to steal
something from a guard's pocket without
them noticing this string can also be
molded or shaped into things like nets
blankets or even manifest as a typical
stand similar to star platinum in this
manifested form it has a range of about
2 meters while the loose string can
stretch much further up to about 24
meters there can also be combined
elements where the full stone free is
manifested and strings will still
offshoot from her as well
jolene can unravel up to 70 of her body
to produce string and an added benefit
of which is she becomes much more
flexible as her body is used up to make
the string the strings can also be used
to eavesdrop stitch up wounds swing like
spider-man detect movement and a bunch
of more straightforward uses like the
net that i've mentioned previously all
in all just a very useful and versatile
stand that makes for a pretty compelling
tool for the protagonist our second
stand google dolls was named after the
band of the same name and was localized
as either gigi dolls or cry cry dolls
depending on the medium the stand
belongs to gwes julian's cellmate and is
designed to look like a mummified monkey
which is fun i guess
physically gooby dolls is definitely on
the weaker side of stands due to its
tiny size however its ability to shrink
others who are in its range definitely
helps to even the odds this shrinking
happens instantly and is unnoticeable by
the victim at first leaving them to be
the size of a mouse for as long as wes
wants or until they're far enough away
from her for the effects to be negated
at which point they will start to grow
back to their normal size our third
stand is manhattan transfer named after
the vocal jazz group the manhattan
transfer this was a drone-like stand
belonging to john gallier the stand
itself does very little and is
essentially a sitting duck however it
does allow john gallier to know the
precise location of his opponents so
that he can snipe them from afar even if
the opponent is hiding bullets can be
ricocheted off of manhattan transfer to
hit them around corners furthermore
manhattan transfer can read air currents
to sense motion to the point that it can
even dodge the prison sprinkler system
it then sends this information back to
john gallier and when combined with his
own talents for sniping it makes for a
deadly stand despite how simple it is
the next stand we learn about in the
series is white snake named after the
band of the same name this one's name
was changed to pale snake and belonged
to enrico pucci one of the most
interesting parts of the stand is that
despite it being owned by poochie it
also seems to have its own
self-awareness and will white snake has
a pretty decent range of about 20 meters
but despite that it's almost as fast and
strong as most close range stands even
being able to keep up with stone free
although probably not able to overpower
them because of this it tends to rely on
ambushes to get the upper hand white
snake has a few main abilities that it
works with first melt your heart and
illusion an acid-based ability that
slowly digests those it covers on top of
this anyone who's caught in the acid
will become trapped in a dream if they
realize they're dreaming if they notice
any errors in the world or if they
receive a shock from the outside world
they'll be able to wake up but they will
still be fairly drained of their energy
in that case this illusion is also seen
to allow him to disguise himself as
other people so it's pretty versatile
secondly is white snake's most useful
ability disc creation this allows him to
extract a person's memory and stand from
their body and put them in discs that
can be put into others or stored away if
both are removed the target will fall
unconscious or could even die
if the memory disc is implanted back in
them though it will revive them however
if only the stand disc is returned the
person can regain consciousness but
their loss of will will result in the
death of the body eventually discs can
also contain instructions or commands
that must be followed steal senses like
vision enable impossible things like a
person exploding or showing strength
greater than their normal limits and so
on it can even turn someone's head into
a music player which is pretty fitting
for the disc theme what i really like
about this stand is just like jolene's
stone free this strength doesn't come
from raw power but instead comes from
versatility and the options that it
presents hermes costello's stan was
named kiss and was named after the hard
rock band of the same name eventually
being localized to smack which is much
less cool unfortunately the main ability
of kiss is its duplicating stickers she
can produce an exact copy of anything
that she puts a sticker on this can even
include biological things like limbs or
a head the copy can go any distance away
however once the sticker is removed the
objects will launch back at each other
and fuse with a pretty devastating force
highway to hell or highway to death is a
stand belonging to thunder mcqueen and
was named after the ac dc song and album
of the same name this stand is unable to
damage others on its own however it does
replicate any damage or unfortunate
situation that the user takes onto
itself
so since thunder mcqueen tries to end
his own life on repeat it becomes
incredibly dangerous for hermes who
becomes linked with him for example if
mcqueen tries to drown himself water
would cover hermes's mouth and nose so
that she would drown as well there also
doesn't seem to be any range limit so
the only way to stop this stand is to
stop mcqueen from trying to end his own
life or to take away the disc with his
stand ability burning the house down
named after the talking head song and
localized as burning down is the stand
of emporio el nino is one of those very
strange and specific stands that each
jojo series tends to incorporate kind of
similar to earth wind and fire from part
5. burning the house down is a stand
with no real form itself but which is
linked to a location and item within the
prison taking on the appearance of a
ghostly music room which was burned down
in the prison in the 1980s this gives
emporio absolutely no abilities in a
fight even the ghostly gun that he has
is pointless as it can't interact with
others to reach this ghostly room a
stand user needs to go through a crack
in one of the walls of the prison
stairwells however as most are unaware
of the stand or imperial in general they
often go ignored foo fighters named
after a band of the same name was
changed to ff for localization reasons
well this is sort of true in both
versions the name is shortened to ff but
the full name foo fighters isn't used in
the localization version at all ff is a
bit of a special case as their mix of
both stand and stand user and beyond
that they aren't even human rather they
are a colony of plankton that has a
stand because ff is made of plankton it
doesn't really have any weaknesses other
than that it might dry out furthermore
as it is a colony it can even split
itself into smaller bodies which will
remain like-minded while independent the
stand has a ton of versatility
durability and strength and even if it's
mostly destroyed and only one piece of
plankton remains that's all that's
really needed for it to survive and if
given water it can start to regain its
form other abilities belonging to foo
fighters includes stealing someone's
body or taking over their consciousness
which will even give her access to
memories manipulating water to some
degree shooting parts of its body out
like a gun and this plankton bullet can
then spread inside of someone else and
take control of them or it can even be
used to make a makeshift stitch or
band-aid to prevent bleeding out if
someone is wounded again this is just
another example of a very versatile
stand that gives a lot of options you
just gotta watch out for sponges because
it's basically game over if she comes
across one
next up is a stand that actively made me
burst out laughing when i saw the
localization
marilyn manson or mary lynne manson is
named after the singer of the same name
and it's just such a lazy localization
it belongs to miroshon and much like the
dobby brothers it works on kind of a
game or gambling system the stand is
actually fairly simple it just ensures
that the rules or conditions of a bet
are stuck to no matter what it will 100
follow through on that wager however it
also is open to listening to reason or
explanations to ensure that the game is
fair for example when being forced to
play a game of catch jolene said that
she never specified who she would play
the game of catch with allowing her to
take the ball back from the prison guard
without any penalty if the original
conditions of the wager cannot be met
substitutes will be made instead for
example if i bet a thousand dollars but
i only have a hundred marilyn manson
might take one of my eyes as payment and
that might be the strangest sentence
i've ever had to say for a video
the stand itself is invincible and can't
take damage while collecting a debt and
it's only able to be stopped either when
it finishes collecting the debt or if
mireshone calls it off or is knocked out
weather report or weather forecast is
named after a jazz fusion band and is
the only example of a man who received
only his stand disc back but remains to
be more or less healthy this is a pretty
powerful stand all things considered
with the ability to control the weather
and the atmosphere it covers all the
bases you might expect creating wind
rain clouds humidity all the normal
weather manipulating stuff however it
can also create localized atmosphere
wind bursts so strong they can pierce
directly through someone create suits
made out of clouds or even freeze
liquids it really is the loosest
variation of the idea of manipulating
weather and the stand has a plethora of
options available at all times the big
example from early on is when it used a
tornado to suck up a bunch of wildlife
and create a rain of poisonous frogs
this also has a bit of an upgraded
version later in the story with heavy
weather named after an album from the
weather report which i really do like
the attention to detail of having the
stand named after the band become one of
their albums it's a very nice touch what
is not so nice is heavy weather itself
this stand is automatically functioning
and fueled by its hatred for humanity he
gets some new abilities in this form
many of which are just kind of strange
for example snail projection
yes you heard me right heavy weather
makes rainbows that will turn anyone
else who touches them into snails it
could be big ones it could be small ones
they could change very slowly or
instantly truly this is the epitome of
power furthermore these snails love to
procreate and they'll begin to spread to
the point that they could even overrun
an entire city if they're not addressed
which again
is both hilarious and terrifying next up
jumpin jack flash named after the
rolling stone song it was localized to
jumping jack spark and the stand belongs
to lang wrangler jumping jack's main
ability is to remove gravity anyone that
he spits on will become the epicenter of
an area with zero gravity which is
completely disorienting and will leave
them vulnerable
on top of this any one or anything that
they touch will also gain these effects
as well while this is a pretty strong
one in itself it can also be used to
create a vacuum within air to drain
blood from open wounds or to boil
people's blood and that's just to name a
few aspects
while lang is not immune to these
effects he has practiced in these
scenarios which helps him quite a bit
along with that he uses suction cups on
his hands and feet to stick to walls and
control the situation a little bit more
easily finally he has centrifuges in
each of his wrists which allow him to
pour objects inside of them and fire
them off like a rifle at high speeds
it's definitely one of the stands that
has a lot more side effects to offer
than others but i think that makes it a
really interesting one even if lang
wrangler looks a bit lame himself
following jumping jack flash we have
what is personally my favorite
localization of any stand in the entire
series well maybe other than filthy
deeds done at a reasonable price but
both of them are phenomenal truly this
is the peak that araki has reached and
he should have put his pen down here
because
limp biscuit
named after the band of the same name
was changed to flaccid
pancake
belonging to a man named sports max with
two x's which is just
amazing when thought about in a package
because
limp biscuit flaccid pancake sports max
oh i love it so much this is an
invisible stand that can bring back the
dead as invisible spirits to attack
enemies flaccid pancake which i refuse
to call limp biscuit from this point on
can bring back people animals or even
its own user in this way once revived
the wraiths can be killed again in
normal ways however their original body
takes the damage wraiths are stronger
than their human forms can walk on walls
and of course they crave for brains and
blood now from here on out most of the
stands don't yet have localized names
although we will likely get them when
the series continues on netflix
depending on how licensing goes diver
down named after the van halen album
belongs to narcisso aniswe whose name i
probably mispronounced this is a pretty
powerful combat stand but it's also
incredibly useful for support its main
ability is to store energy or damage so
if it hits something the damage can be
stored up until a time of his choosing
for example i could punch a wall 50
times and then trigger all of the
impacts in one moment to increase the
force drastically that said he could
also use this ability to effectively
negate damage that an ally might take on
top of this diver down has the ability
to phase in or dive into objects or
people then manipulating or changing
them however he'd like
he can destroy them he can help them by
removing things like parasitic plants
it's just a super useful and great
supporting tool on top of just being
pretty powerful in its own right
guccio's stan's survivor is named after
the band of the same name it isn't
particularly powerful and dio even
called it the weakest of all stands but
it is incredibly frustrating this is an
uncontrollable automatic stand which
consists of several small creatures and
it exists
purely to create mayhem
basically this stand sends a small shock
into its target that will make them want
to fight those around them anyone
affected becomes a better fighter
ignores pain and can see the muscles and
weak points of their enemy ensuring a
pretty good brawl like i said it's
pretty simple not at all threatening but
if you've looked into the series at all
you know how aggressive all of the
characters can be especially in part 6
and survivor just cranks that all up to
the max
sports max
planet waves named after the bob dylan
album and belonging to viviano westwood
is a stand that we don't actually see
fight we know it is insanely dangerous
though as it has the ability to attract
meteoroids down to earth and towards a
person of their choosing any meteor
which might accidentally hit the user
will disintegrate while others that
target enemies come in at insane speeds
and temperatures up to 3000 degrees
these meteoroids will continue to fall
every few seconds or minutes until
they're called off and that said most of
them are fairly small so they can be
obstructed however larger ones could be
called down as well dragon's dream which
i think is named after a book written by
roger dean although i couldn't really
find confirmation please let me know in
the comments down below if you do know
is the stand of kenzo this stand is
basically a sentient dragon that can act
independently of kenzo similar to
marilyn manson the stand not the singer
dragon's dream acts as a judge during
fights and aims to keep things as fair
as possible the stand doesn't attack on
its own and leaves kenzo to take on
enemies however that said kenzo does get
a boost in his own abilities because he
has dragon's dream this makes him an
expert in feng shui and is honestly one
of the more complicated stands to
explain but the gist of it is that he
can read signals sent from dragon's
stream to make himself aware of lucky
spots where he can easily dodge things
or unlucky spots where he can get
critical strikes on his opponents
sometimes even mortal wounds the stand
more or less turns the fight into a
mini-game that allows him to get major
bonuses to both his survivability and
lethality if he's doing well as dragon
dream aims for neutrality though he will
warn the opponent about these points and
explain his abilities before going into
the fight yo-yo ma named after the
chinese musician belongs to dng and it
is another automatic stand however this
one is incredibly smart and nearly
indestructible its core ability is to
spit acid on people which will not do
any noticeable harm nor cause any pain
but instead it will eat up them very
slowly and secretly it's kind of up to
them to notice and to do something about
it once given an order or a goal yoyoma
will just work independently towards
that goal until it's achieved green
green grass of home named after the
porter wagner song belongs to the green
baby it is composed of 36 souls and acts
to protect the green baby similar to
guber dolls green green grass shrinks
others however this is more of an
automated system the closer anything
gets to the green baby the smaller it
will become similarly as they start to
move out of the range they will start
returning to their usual size
once someone gets too close to the baby
though and have reached their smallest
point green green grass will appear to
attack them looking like a titan in
comparison finally if the baby does pick
something up or becomes interested in it
they will return to their normal size
jailhouse lock named after the elvis
song jailhouse rock and belonging to
miyuka mueller this one is pretty
interesting as it limits the way its
targets are able to act it does so by
making it so that they can only remember
three new pieces of information after
they touch the walls or bars of the
visiting room in the jail it can also be
activated if muka sends these stand to
actually target someone as well though
anyone affected by jailhouse lock will
keep their old memories however as soon
as the stand is activated they will only
be able to learn three new things
anything beyond that will make them lose
the first new thing that they've learned
essentially locking them out of any
complex tasks and eventually ruining
their ability to think miuka tends to
take advantage of this by giving new
information in rapid succession
completely disorienting the target
moving into our last 5 sea moon named
after the song by wing and localized as
full moon is another stand used by
enrico pucci specifically this is the
fusion of poochie and the green baby it
visually takes on a few traits of white
snake like the pattern across his body
and its crown however it gains a couple
new tricks
this is a remote control stand that can
shift gravity anything within three
kilometers of poochie can have its
gravity shifted to be pushed away from
poochie this can also just straight up
launch things off the planet if they're
not tied down it also gives him a bit of
mobility options as well allowing him to
walk vertically up walls by pulling his
feet towards any surface that they're
touching or even allowing him to
levitate obviously this ability can be
turned off whenever poochie wants
because if he wasn't able to he would
just never be able to be near anything
ever of course the abilities don't stop
there if seamun touches or punches
anything they will turn inside out if
hit again they will revert back to
normal which doesn't sound like a great
time while in general this is incredibly
dangerous it can also be used
defensively as pucci can turn himself
inside out to avoid damage lastly sea
moon can accelerate time in a small area
touched by or near pucci for example
growing one half of a baby to be an
adult or instantly turning eggs into
full-grown chickens
that said poochie can't really control
this ability and it will activate
without his discretion bohemian rap city
is obviously named after the queen's
song and is a stan belonging to jungalo
this affects the entire world and can
bring fictional characters from media
into reality which like
i mean i'd be okay with this one
sticking around for a bit
now it's not all good times in waifus
though as when you come across a
character you like your soul becomes
dragged into that character's place in
their original story the soul and body
become divided similar to white snakes
discs and only the sole portion of you
can use stands furthermore if you die in
that story you die in real life
even if you know what's going to happen
in that story nothing can change that
character's path so if you were to
become gwen stacy there is no amount of
back braces in the world that could keep
you alive
the only way out of that situation is to
kill the manifested version of that
character in the real world people who
live under rocks actually have a bit of
advantage against the stand as if you
don't have any affiliation towards the
character brought to life you'll be
unaffected however if dozens of
characters are brought into the real
world at once it's pretty unlikely that
you won't know any of them the only real
way to defeat the stand is for a writer
to create a character that can erase
other fictional characters which is
pretty meta sky high named after the
jigsaw song belongs to riccial this is a
bit of a weird one which allows rickiel
to control things called rods or skyfish
these float in the air and move so fast
that you can't see them with the normal
eye but they can be picked up by cameras
which since they're entirely based on
the idea of cryptids is pretty fun their
main ability is to absorb people's body
heat to fuel themselves something which
can result in the victim facing several
diseases or illnesses basically they
drain people's heat until they get sick
but if they want they can also localize
the heat drain to a very specific point
of the body this can lead to effects
like blinding the enemy by forcing their
eyelids shut shutting down or rotting
muscles making people see things with
delay or lag
forcing people to die by slowing their
brain or heart or even numbing pain for
rickial it's very versatile for
something so simple as draining heat and
it has a pretty fun theme our second
last stand is underworld named after the
band of the same name and belonging to
donatello vs this is another stand which
offers almost no combat ability but it
does support its user in the fight the
main ability of underworld is to bring
up memories or events from the past that
he pulls from the earth or from bodies
within it the core idea is that the
ground remembers everything that happens
on it
this is similar to bohemian rhapsody as
it traps its victims in another reality
underworld can place targets within
memories such as something devastating
like a plane or car crash or something
fun like a football game really any
situation could be brought up as long as
he's able to dig up the correct memory
once in that memory it's up to the
target to find a way out of it through
loopholes in the situation for example
if you find someone who survives the
memory you can always use them as some
kind of protection by following their
lead as you might expect for a memory
based ability you can also use the stand
to take information from someone as well
and our last stand is made in heaven
which is a reference to the freddie
mercury song it is also the final stand
of enrico pucci this stand is so
powerful that dio actually refers to it
as the ultimate stand and the key to
heaven and when dio is praising
something that is not himself
it's probably something we should really
consider while see moon was the fusion
of poochie and green baby this soul was
formed when 36 others joined them so
lots of setup what can it actually do
though as it is the big bad stand for a
jojo series it obviously has time
manipulating powers once activated time
will begin to speed up more and more
across the entire universe but no living
thing other than pucci can keep up with
it something which basically makes him a
god the delay is so big that people in
cold places will instantly freeze anyone
driving a vehicle will crash immediately
people are just unable to react to
anything that happens around them which
as you might guess leads to quite a few
deaths this is to the point that even
star platinum who can freeze time has no
chance of keeping up with him and the
wild part
this isn't even the ability that poochie
was trying to achieve
this is a secondary one the big effect
is universal reset as time moves forward
the universe eventually hits its
vanishing point and a new universe
begins where all things move according
to fate any and all living things will
be brought into the new universe to a
time and place chosen by pucci and
anyone who died will be replaced by a
parallel version of themselves though
they will essentially be entirely
different people on top of this all
people will remember their previous
universe life and this means that they
will also know what will happen to them
in the future a method thought up by
poochie to make people accept fate
finally if poochie happens to be killed
before the universe resets again a new
alternate timeline will begin leading us
into part 7 steel ball run and that's it
every new stand that we meet in stone
ocean yes we see some returning stands
like star platinum or we see references
to the world here and there in this
series but those are pre-existing stands
if you really need a quick definition
for those ones they go unga bunga they
punch things real hard they can stop
time briefly the end this was actually a
really fun video to make though and i
hope you all enjoyed it as much as i did
if you did remember to leave a like and
be sure to comment what kind of stone
ocean content you would like to see from
me going forward
and of course you need to be sure to hit
that subscribe button and select all
notifications to be aware of those
videos once they actually come out you
can also follow anime uproar at
animeopera on twitter and instagram or
you can follow myself at excellionyt i
want to take a moment to thank all of
our amazing anime uproar patrons for
making videos like this possible a
special thanks to alpha sigma and kyle
salisbury who are disciples of lord
tuigo himself
as well as are the one tier patrons who
rise above all others with ingrada al
jatal pate jefe the red-haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike 8227
lonely dakar spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkus baked buddhist jeremy cummings
and che whitley finally a big thanks to
our pro hero tier patrons gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz very gucci alicia
octor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips alivania temple
king mathy and demetrius water if you
enjoy these videos and want to support
the channel a little bit please consider
checking out our patreon for as little
as one dollar a month you will gain
access to our exclusive discord and get
your name at the end of these videos
just like all these amazing people while
also just supporting the channel in
general thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time stay
excellent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]